well Israeli forces have now also
carried out more raids and arrests
overnight in the occupied West Bank we
can now speak to Imran Khan he joins us
from rala Imran we know that these raids
and arrests have been escalating are
they they're continuing to do
so that's absolutely right we've
actually heard from a senior military
commander in the occupied West Bank and
Israeli who says the gloves are now off
in dealing with Palestinian uh
Palestinians within the occupied West
Bank and these raids are contining in
fact even as we speak there is a raid in
tubas in the northwest of the occupied
West Bank we're hearing at least five
Palestinians have been injured there by
Israeli Army uh
85 uh were arrested uh overnight these
raids took place between about 3 and 5:
in the morning uh there was one in the
village of kobar northwest of rala
that's the one I actually heard it was
really near where we are about four or 5
km away and we could hear the St
grenades and we can hear those sound
bomb bombs going off that lasts until
about 5: in the morning there also raids
in Hebron and biddu um and we're hearing
that about
1,450 Palestinians have been arrested
since October the 7th now that increases
the number of Palestinians in jail to
66600 of those are actually been
arrested without charge and also the
death tolls are increasing as well even
here in the occupied West Bank 104 since
October 7th and Imran I see there have
been more protests in front of the Red
Cross office there in
rala that's absolutely right uh families
of the red uh families of the people who
have been arrested have actually gone
into the icrc building they've delivered
a letter to the International Red
Crescent workers there and they've said
uh that Israel needs to do much more
than it's doing to help these people at
least find out information about their
families they want to put pressure on
the icrc to put pressure on Israel
whether actually the icrc can do that or
not remains to be seen but uh as we're
speaking it's actually worth just
pointing out to you uh you can probably
hear it there are some protesters now
coming uh into the main Square in rala
but what's actually intriguing are those
um Palestinian uh Security Forces there
uh they're actually armed we don't
really see that in Manara Square this
the first time we're actually seeing
that since uh during the day at least uh
so I don't know why they're out in such
big number the protests do happen quite
regularly here in Manara Square um this
is perhaps a sign of the tensions here
out on the streets on the occupied West
Bank uh people are very angry at
everything that they've been seeing uh
all of those pictures that they've been
seeing coming out of Gaz I've said this
to you before nstasia and it hasn't
changed people are still really afraid
that what's happening in Gaza could
still happen here in the occupied West
Bank Imran Khan there on the ground
forest in rala in the occupied West Bank
thank you Imran